The Joe Rogan experience,
and so when you asked me do I infiltrate,
it's like,
no,
do I?
Do I watch a steady diet of Fox News?
No.
Do I read right when you
decide to all the time?
No.
Do I try to read stuff from all over
the world from different points of view.
Why Greg?
Because it's interesting.
You don't have to agree with everything
you read and I only say this to people
about comedy,
the people that come and see you and don't
like your politics and then get up in
a huff and fuck off.
I always think you're not sophisticated,
not sophisticated and I don't
mean that in like a smart Aleck.
You went to college way.
I mean there are people
who have no education,
who can understand a whole bunch of
ideas at once and see the humor of.
You know what I mean?
Well,
there's some people,
there's lines you cannot cross.
Their pea brains won't allow it,
but that's what I mean.
Like come on to subject at top limits.
Mostly I find that if you are disagreeing,
I remember last year or two years
ago when the election was going,
I did a joke in Eugene or Portland or no,
one of the places in Oregon,
it wasn't Eugene,
which is wicked liberal,
but it was a like Klamath.
Well,
I don't know where the
fuck it was in Oregon.
There was a city in Oregon and uh,
I said something I said to the Republican
nominees aren't just the worst group
of nominees I've ever seen from the
Republican Party in my lifetime.
There the roots group of people
I've ever seen in a room,
you know,
and started to go through them.
And one was Herman Cain and newcomer
and someone in the back yelled,
no.
It was like,
no,
you don't get to veto jokes and a guy,
I'm not kidding.
A Guy wrote me the other day on my email.
Like I take email from
people and I read it.
I don't always answer,
but any raw.
I was at your show in
Chicago and it was a podcast.
So my pockets is not
advertised as a standup show.
It says podcast,
you know,
like,
and therefore there's a
different thing that's happening,
it's a lot more real and you know,
as you know,
and he wrote me,
he said,
ah,
I didn't spend the 20 bucks or whatever
to hear your fucking politics and I
didn't think it was very funny and anyone
that would like to show it would be a
halfwit and shit.
So normally I would just block.
I mean now,
but I thought I'm going to
run him back and I wrote,
you're hostile.
Tone is not conducive to
discourse and understand this.
You chose to come in
the room and you pay it.
If you'd ask for a refund of the time,
that's another matter.
And I go,
and by the way,
after the show's over,
you don't get to email the artist and
ask for your money back because you
disagreed with them.
You take your chances.
Whether you go to see a symphony or a
movie or a fucking whatever it is you're
going to go see,
man,
when you go to Jack in the box,
you might not like them sausages,
but you don't get to fucking write me
after and tell me you want your money
back.
And then say everyone that liked it was
a moron when he was the only one who
didn't like it,
you know,
and it's like,
I don't understand that.
Well,
there's always going to be people that
can't wrap their head around the idea
that there's different people and
different people like different stuff.
And if you don't like something it's okay.
If there are other people enjoying it,
well then you know that's for
them and it's not for you.
But the anger letter like I didn't,
I don't like your politics and fucking
that wasn't very funny and the people are
assholes and just sending that letter,
you're an asshole.
He mean you might want to
tell one of your friends like,
I didn't have a good time.
He's talking all this liberal shit.
Trayvon Martin.
Not yet.
The night I,
I did it was the 50th anniversary of
the march on Washington for jobs and
freedom and I played a clip of Martin
Luther King speech the part I have a dream
and shit,
you know,
because I didn't think the crowd had
heard it before because a lot of young
people haven't heard it exactly.
And everybody listen really intently and
I thought this is what you objected to.
You objected to the biggest cry for
peace in the last fucking 50 years.
The,
the idea of getting out of your own way.
That's a big one.
How'd you figure that out?
I mean probably the same way you did.
You know what I mean?
I think it's the,
it's anybody that's trying to do
anything in art or filmmaking,
painting,
whatever it is you find or,
or sports or golf particularly.
You find that the tendency
is to try too hard.
Right?
You're so you want it so bad,
you don't want to screw up.
You want to get it right.
You want to not embarrass yourself.
And so you wind up trying,
trying,
trying so hard that nothing comes,
you know.
And finally,
like over over time,
I'm sure this is the same for everybody.
You kind of say to yourself,
man,
I just have to lighten up
a little bit because when,
when good things happen is
when I'm not trying so hard.
And in many ways I think that's
the hardest thing of all.
I mean obviously what you're
saying about being in the jungle,
you know,
psychedelic juggle,
what that's really all
about is not trying.
It's like,
it's like the hardest thing
in the world is to say,
somebody says to you,
relax,
right?
Or be yourself,
just be yourself,
Joe.
You know,
I mean,
and,
and yet I think as we
become more professional and
better at what we're doing,
when somebody says to you,
be yourself,
you can,
you know,
you're not burdened by these false
selves and these things that,
uh,
that you think you ought
to be or ought to say,
or how you want to look
or what you ought to be.
You've kind of gotten rid of those,
you know,
over time,
deliberately,
very deliberately.
And I certainly have,
you know,
I mean,
I've very deliberately tried,
you know,
when I feel myself going that
way to pull back and let go.
But,
and I think in many ways that's what
any artist does as they become a
professional at what they do,
they learned to kind of
get out of their own way.
And it's the hardest thing of all,
I think,
and the people we talk about resistance
or the way people screw themselves up,
right?
That's how they screw
themselves up is they're in,
they're getting in their own way,
right?
They're listening to their own bullshit,
they're believing it and,
and they're.
And they're blocked from
whatever they're trying to do.
I'm sure that's what the comics right
when they get on stage and they bomb,
right?
That's what's happening.
Yeah.
That definitely is a big part of it.
The,
the,
the what,
what,
what I think you're doing that or think
is really cool is that by living your
life and figuring things out and
then documenting and sharing them,
sharing them like in a really honest way,
we are all providing together
what's basically a direction
manual on how to live
your life and avoid a lot of bullshit
that most people get involved with.
This is right.
This is the stuff they
don't teach you in school.
Exactly because they don't know we're
trying to do now is the real problem is
the human body and the human mind is
probably the most complicated vehicle that
the world has ever seen.
Forget about all the rocket ships and
all the different things that you have to
go through years and years of school
before they let you fuck with whether it's
f 18 fighter jets or helicopters.
There's,
there's,
I watched a friend get
his pilot's license.
Just studying all aerodynamics
and all these different things.
You have to know to take the test and
winds and you don't have to do shit to be
a person.
You're just a person.
I mean,
it's way crazier to operate this thing.
I mean it has emotions attached to it.
It can make other people with his penis,
which it likes rubbing.
This is ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous animal
and it's a ridiculous sort
of a thing to try to manage
with no help and by you writing
this book and people sharing their,
their own personal experiences and this.
One of the things that young
men appreciate the most
about old men is an old man
who will tell you what he did wrong.
Like when I meet young kids and was like,
dude,
listen to me.
I'm not going to bullshit you,
but don't do that.
Whatever you do,
don't do this one because
that one's stupid.
Of course nobody listens.
People do.
But if there's an old expression that
a wise man learns from the mistakes of
others,
makes his own.
It was owed.
Yeah.
You're a fucking human being.